every year about 8 million tons of waste
lavas are dumped into the Indian rivers
all the pesticides and insecticides that
we used to grow these flowers mixes with
the river water making it highly toxic
we decided to do something about it
[Music]
Indians depends on the river water for
drinking water for our agriculture and
for our basic needs in Hinduism we
Hindus go to temples and offer flowers
to all gods
once these flowers have been offered to
our gods they become sacred they cannot
be dumped in the hospital so according
to religious customs they are dumped
into the river Ganges
once these flowers have been dumped in
the river it creates havoc in the
fragile ecosystem of the water body we
had decided that we want to solve the
flower problem but we didn't have a
solution so we started going to temples
biding for the race class but turned out
no one would trust us boys coming and
asking you for waste you're not sure
what they'll do with it so slowly slowly
he started with around twelve kilos of
these flowers and in a month we started
collecting 80 kilograms of these flaws
today our trucks go to the temple
directly click these blades flowers in
bins and bring them to a facility we
have a capacity of about eight point
seven tons of estas burning these
flowers are treated to remove all the
pesticides and insecticides and convert
them into products we make charcoal free
incense sticks bathing bars and now we
are launching biodegradable alternative
styrofoam made from these base flowers
river Ganges is the holiest river in the
world
it says a dip in the river Ganges can
remove all your sins where I see river
Ganges in the state that it is in have
inside and I feel that the status quo
needs to be changed
[Music]
you